Einsatz gegen illegale Migration wir
sind mit der Bundespolizei an
Deutschlands Grenzen unterwegs auf der
Schiene auf der Straße und in der Luft
wollen herausfinden wie die Beamten an
Brennpunkten gegen steigende
flüchltingszahlen und rücksichtslose
Schleuser Vorgehen erste Station Basel
Deutschs schweizerische
Grenze hallo Polizeikontrolle ein
Ausweis
bitte ein ICE noch bevor dieser
deutschen Boden erreicht ein
Sonderabkommen mit der Schweiz macht's
möglich einreisen können so noch vor dem
Grenzübertritt verhindert werden viel
Zeit bleibt nicht bis zum nächsten Halt
sind es nur 6 Minuten wir versuchen
diesem Zug die unlaubte Einreise nach
Deutschland zu verhindern und gehen
jetzt jedes ab teil und schauen nach
Personen wo da unsere rasche passen z.B
wo gar kein oder wenig Gepäck dabei
haben wo einfach vom p oder
verscheinungsbild unser Raster passen
gleich zu Beginn der Kontrolle werden
Tarik und Natalie auf einen jungen Mann
aufmerksam schnell stellt sich heraus er
stammt aus maroko besitzt zwar einen
Pass aber kein gültiges
Visum zudem verstrickt sich in
Widersprüche er wolle eigentlich nach
Amsterdam erlärt
erter von einer Freundin in Basel Tarik
versucht mit ihm auf Arabisch zu
sprechen kann mal sagen dass er den Zug
mit uns verlassen
muss wir haben jetzt hier marokkanischen
Staatsangehörigen festgestellt er war
nur im Besitz vom Reisepass ihm fehlt
praktisch der aufenitstitel also Visum
für die Einreise nach Deutschland und
deshalb muss die Person jetzt mit uns
den Zug verlassen ja please go
out hallo hier hey take
statt mit dem ICE weiterzureisen geht es
jetzt für den aufgegriffenen Mann in die
sogenannte bearbeitungsstraße am
Badischen Bahnhof Basel Fotos
Registrierung Fingerabdrücke jede
aufgegriffene Person durchläuft hier
erkennungsdienstliche Maßnahmen mit uns
reden will der Mann aus dem Zug nicht
jetzt muss die Person praktisch
registriert werden das heißt wir machen
jetzt ein kurzen aufgrffbericht weil wir
praktisch die aufgreifenden Beamten
waren und danach geht c hier weiter die
Person wird dann den Schweizer Behörden
übergeben und die Schweizer machen das
dann in ihrer eigenen Zuständigkeit
weiter doch das heißt auch viele
versuchen es an einem der anderen 43
grenzübergäng einfach erneut denn
Deutschland ist für viele Migranten ein
lang ersehntes Ziel und die Schweiz
guckt nicht immer so genau hin allein
bis September stellten die Beamten mehr
als 12000 illegale Einreisen in der
gesamten Region fest schon jetzt mehr
als im vergangenen Jahr auch auch
deshalb wurde die Polizeipräsenz zuletzt
weiter erhöht doch nicht nur an der
Schweizer auch an der
deutsch-französischen Grenze ist die
Bundespolizei im Einsatz hier setzen sie
auch auf den Superpuma eines der
effektivsten Einsatzmittel der
Bundespolizei die Piloten fliegen mit
ihrem 3600 PS Hubschrauber
deutsch-französische verandungstrups an
die Grenze mit ihren aufwendigen Flügen
wollen Sie immer einen Schritt schneller
als Schleuser sein und vor allem
unvorhersehbar so wird in neuen Burg
Südbaden jetzt in minutenchnelle für sie
eine Kontrollstelle errichtet wir haben
ein Bodenteam die die ein kleines Team
die die Kontrollstelle aufbauen da wird
auch festgelegt wer als erstes dann
vorne selektiert oder einwei die
Kollegen die sind erfahrene Kollegen die
wissen worauf sie schauen müssen die
schicken uns dann die Fahrzeuge raus
Cedrik Habicht ist Einsatzleiter er
koordiniert zwei fandungstrups die
zeitgleich mehrere Kontrollen auf
deutschem oder französischem Gebiet in
der Nähe von grenzübergäng durchführen
eines ihrer Ziele illegale Einreisen
verhindern die Kooperation mit der
französischen Gendamerie bringt dabei
Vorteile wenn wir in solchen
grenzüberschreitenden Einsätzen sind und
den französischen Kollegen der
jeanemarie mit dabei haben er kann
sofort die Daten im französischen System
kontrollieren schon eines der ersten
Autos ein Treffer zwar handelt es sich
nicht um Migranten doch die Beamten
nehmen es ernst denn auch andere
Straftaten stehen auf der Tagesordnung
in diesem Fall wollte der französische
Fahrer nur mal kurz hinter der Grenze
billige Zigaretten Einkaufen okay die es
entwickelt sich gerade ein wenig in eine
andere Richtung also Versicherung ist
vielleicht nicht gültig aber was
schlimmer ist es gibt kein Führerschein
für der Fahrer dieser ist nicht mehr
gültig Andreas Persch arbeitet als
Leiter der deutschfanzösischen Einheit
eng mit den Kollegen der französischen
gend Marie zusammen sie werden den
Fahrer jetzt Anzeigen er muss zu Fuß
nach Hause innerhalb kürzester Zeit
kontrolliert die Einheit weitere
Fahrzeuge grundsätzlich verdächtig sind
momentan vor allem Transporter mit
mehreren Menschen an Bord es könnte ein
schleuserfahrzeug mit Flüchtlingen sein
doch erstmal ist alles in Ordnung die
Polizei deckt an diesem Standort nur
kleinere Delikte auf so finden Sie einen
Kofferraum voll Textilien mit
gefälschten Modelabels und auch eine
illegale Waffe ja wir haben im
Handschuhfach des einfahrers ein
Butterflymesser gefunden das ist eine
verbotener Gegenstand Deutschland das
heißt man darf den nicht mal besitzen
stellt eine straft da Verstoß nach dem
Waffengesetz dann kommt der Superpuma
wieder schnell soll es zur nächsten
Kontrolle gehen wo wieder ein mögliches
einfalltstor für Schleuser wartet
Kollegin auf dem Heimweg hat gerade
gemeldet D im schönram Recht am Brauhaus
eine Person steht die telefoniert WR
Einsatz rund um die Uhr auch an der
Grenze zu Österreich auch Sie ein
Hotspot für illegale Migration im
Einsatz Kommissarin Caroline Nowak und
ihr Kollege Nico hattel früh am Morgen
wird in der Ortschaft schönramm ein
junger Mann gesichtet Verdacht auf
unerlaubte Einreise aufgrund der
Sprachbarriere versucht mein Kollege das
jetzt mittels Google Übersetzer alles zu
klären den Sachverhalten er konnte uns
bis jetzt nur schildern dass er mit dem
LKW irgendwoh hin der gegen mit weiteren
vier Personen abgesetzt wurde von dem
Schleuser fehlt jede Spur Minuten später
vier Personen werden auf der Dorfstraße
gemeldet Carolin Nowak und Nico Hartel
versuchen sie zu beruhigen und eine
erste Kontaktaufnahme
Türkisch und
türkisch gehst du mal vor dann gehe ich
hintenan okay follow me Einsätze im
Minutentakt für Noak und Hartel nichts
Ungewöhnliches hier an der Grenze zu
Österreich sind es manchmal 100 Menschen
am Tag allein bis September hat die
Bundespolizei in der Region über 18 000
unerlaubte einreisen festgestellt
Tendenz steigend der älteste der
viererguppe bricht in Tränen aus er hat
auf der Flucht seinen Sohn verloren
Harel erreicht ein arabisch dolmetcher
Verständigung über
[Musik]
Handylautsprecher zurück im
Streifenwagen solche Aufgriffe haben sie
hier täglich erzählt uns Kommissarin
Nowak viele Flüchtlinge hätten Angst
sein verunsichert oder wie bei dem Mann
eben auf der Flucht von der Familie
getrennt worden wie geht man damit um
ich glaube es ist wichtig menschlich zu
bleiben aber irgendwie auch so eine
gewisse Distanz im Dienst auch versuchen
aufzubauen man kann ja nicht jedes
Schicksal mit nach Hause nehmen bei der
Bundespolizei in Freilassing reichen die
Container nicht mehr aus für ankommende
Flüchtlinge wurden Zelte errichtet und
Feldbetten aufgebaut die Einsatzkräfte
hier arbeiten täglich am Anschlag und
die Belastung nimmt zu außerdem haben
sie es hier mit immer brutaleren
Schleusern zu tun wir erleben Schleusung
in kastenwegen mit 20 bis 30 Personen
die unter teils lebensgefährdenen
Umständen nach Deutschland verbracht
werden und wenn wir nicht ermitteln
würden wie diese einreiseumstände Z
standande gekommen sind wann die
Personen nach Deutschland eingereist
sind und welche Kontaktdaten Sie
möglicherweise noch verfügen könnten wir
dem ein oder anderen Schleuser das
Handwerk nicht legen wie rücksichtslos
die Schleuser Vorgehen zeigt dieser Fall
im Oktober in einem Auto das eigentlich
für neun Personen zugelassen ist zwängen
sich 23 Menschen aus der Türkei und
Syrien als die Polizei den Fahrer
kontrollieren will rast der davon kommt
von der Straße ab und überschlägt sich
am Ende sind sieben Menschen tot
darunter ein sechsjähriges Kind solche
Bilder haben auch sie immer vor Augen
Carolin Nowak und Nico hattel auf
Streife im Grenzgebiet sie suchen zwei
Flüchtlinge die von Schleusern
ausgesetzt wurden plötzlich auf einem
Feldweg neben der Landstraße zwei junge
Männer ID passport
ID es handelt sich um zwei Kurden sie
sind nicht allein erzählen sie insgesamt
sein es fünf Autos gewesen allein in
ihrem saßen 12 Personen das manche
Schleuser Kolonne fahren hat für Noak
und Hartel System da fährt z.B ein
scoutfahrzeug voraus versucht
auszukundschaften ob die Lage sicher ist
ob Polizei in der Nähe ist und dann
folgt das schleuserfahrzeug das sind
manchmal zwei Leute dann in einem Auto
also ein Schleuser ein geschleuser
manchmal haben wir Kastenwägen die sind
voll beladen mit über 20 Leuten auf der
Suche nach den schleäusern das
Einsatzgebiet ist Ries sich oft
erleichtern Hinweise aus der Bevölkerung
den Polizeikräften die Arbeit am Ende
zählt vor allem
Erfahrung sag mal die älteren Kollegen
die kennen hier auch die verwinkelsten
Ecken aber das Lernen die uns dann schon
und ja jede Schicht lernt man
mehr zurück an die deutschschweizerische
Grenze Natalie und Tarik unterstützen in
ihrer 12 Stunden Schicht jetzt ihre
Kollegen und zwar an einem der
wichtigsten autogrenzübergänge
Deutschlands weil am rein
Kontrollen sind hier nicht vollkommen
neu doch seit Mitte Oktober seitdem
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fer
stationäre Grenzkontrollen bei der EU
angemeldet hat können diese theoretisch
wieder rund um die Uhr stattfinden aber
wie entscheiden sie eigentlich innerhalb
von Sekunden ob und welche Autos sie
rausziehen das sind grundsätzlicher
lageinationen die wir so nicht rausgeben
können es wird aber schon geschaut wie
das KFZ an sich aufgebaut ist ob da eben
genug Platz wä für weitere Personen
vielleicht im hinteren Bereich weil das
auch einfach ein Vorgehen ist was öfter
erfasst wurde kurz darauf dieser LKW aus
dem Ausland weckt das Interesse der
Beamten
polikontrolk okay sie wollen sich das
Fahrzeug genauer ansehen zwar gibt es
dafür genaue Vorgaben doch jede
Kontrolle ist anders und jede wirgt
Unwegbarkeiten ein leicht mulmiges
Gefühl ist so auch bei Natalie immer mit
dabei obwohl die Freiburger Polizistin
schon seit mehr als 15 Jahren im Dienst
ist ja sch natürlich auf alles gefasst
also der Zeitpunkt bis die Plane
hochgeht ist dann immer schon spannend
ja wenn natürlich dann irgendwie 20
Personen auf dem LKW wären und Darter
noch Kinder weiß auch nie in Wasem
Zustand die Personen dann sind doch
Migranten im Fall der Fälle abfangen und
einfach zurückschicken das ist hier für
die Beamten anders als vor auf Schweizer
Hoheitsgebiet nicht ohne weiteres
möglich wenn jemand keine gültigen
Papiere für die Einreise nach
Deutschland hat wird er in die
bearbeitungsstraße mitgenommen und je
nachdem ob die Person dann Asylbegehren
äußert dann zur landeserstaufnahme
Einrichtung nach Freiburg weitergeleitet
oder eben kein Asylbegehren äußert dann
führen wir eben die Zurückweisung in die
Schweiz durch knapp 100 km nördlich an
der französischdeutschen Grenze zum
Entspannen bleibt nur wenig Zeit wieder
will der fahandungstrupp unberechenbar
sein diesmal führt ein kurzer Flug
entlang des Rheins in die Nähe von
Offenburg hier haben die Kollegen und
die nächste Kontrollstelle aufgebaut
zwei Beamte beobachten den Verkehr und
bestimmen aus polizeilicher Sicht wer
kontrolliert werden soll das Thema
illegale Einreise beschäftigt die
Bundespolizei auch
hier wir müssen alle Grenzen im Blick
behalten und natürlich wäre auch eine
verstärkte Kontrolle in der Schweiz
könnte dazu führen dass Ausweichrouten
mehr genutzt werden und das wäre
natürlich auch eine Route über
Frankreich erstmal bleibt hier alles
ruhig die Kontrollen ergeben nichts
Verdächtiges und doch die hubschraubber
sprungfandung bringt Polizei und Zoll
enorme Vorteile zeitgleich können bis zu
vier Kontrollteams an unterschiedlichen
Orten gleichzeitig arbeiten
Schnelligkeit ist hierbei der Trumpf
gegen alle die der Polizei gerne aus dem
Weg gehen möchten es gibt auf Facebook
facebookgruppen wo dann extra für
Kontrollstellen in den Regionen drin
sind das schnellste was bei uns mal war
waren 10 Minuten dann stand drinne hier
eine Kontrollstelle stelle somit wissen
die relativ schnell Bescheid weil die
sind ja dann meistens auch dort aktiv
deswegen versuchen man dann kurze
Einsatzräume kurze kontrollzeiten zu
haben um dann schnell zu verlegen
Ortswechsel an die östliche Grenze
Deutschlands die A17 zwischen Prag und
Dresden zentrale Route zwischen
Osteuropa und Deutschland auch hier soll
durch stationäre Kontrollen für
Schleuser kein Durchkommen mehr sein
seit mehr als zwei Wochen wird daher
rund um die Uhr kontrolliert die Bundes
Polizisten schauen jedem der rund 15 000
Fahrer pro Tag ins Gesicht auch jeder
Reisebus wird angehalten dieser kommt
aus Bulgarien an Bord 39 Menschen alle
müssen ihre Pässe zeigen gleichzeitig
wird das Innere des Busses durchsucht
dann schauen wir uns die Toiletten an
nicht dass da in einer Toilette
vielleicht noch eine Person drin sitzt
welche nicht Erlaubnis hat nach
Deutschland einzisen es geht Schlag auf
Schlag ein Bus nach dem anderen kommt
hier der flixbus von Budapest nach
Berlin viele junge Menschen sind im Bus
unterwegs Generation Europa für die
offene Grenzen eine
Selbstverständlichkeit sind morgens 7
Uhr aus dem Schlaf gerissen hat hier
kaum einer Verständnis für die neuen
Grenzkontrollen das ist gegen Recht der
Menschen ich beeile mich z.B zum Seminar
und jetzt verstehe ich dass ich das
nicht
schaffe
hier ist Europa und wir haben
Schengen für mich ist das nur
kompliziert ich muss raus ich muss mein
Pass zeigen ich mag das nicht ich will
schlafen doch solche sehen wird es wohl
noch öfter geben denn genau wie zu Polen
und der Schweiz bleiben diese
neueschaffenen festen Kontrollen
mindestens noch bis Mitte November
längerung möglich die Entscheidung liegt
in Berlin die meisten Autofahrer haben
sich hier damit arrangiert ich find's
gut das muss meinwgen auch noch mehr
davon und jeden
Tag weil da sind zu viele Schieber und
und Schleuser die da viel Geld dran
verdienen die Leute ins Elend stürzen wo
feste Kontrollen sind kommen aber kaum
noch Schleuser sie weichen aus etwa über
die grüne
Grenze wir haben vor ca 30 Minuten ein
bgerhinweis erhalten den gehen wir nach
und konnten im Verlauf dort in dieser
Nähe 14 Personen feststellen davon sechs
Kinder laut eigenen Angaben handelt es
sich hier um sische Staatsangehörige wir
fahren mit zur Polizeidirektion bergis
Hübel direkt an der
deutsch-tschechischen Grenze hier kommen
die aufgegriffenen illegalen Migranten
an werden erst versorgt zwei Frauen
sechs Kinder im polizeizelt nebenan
liegen ser in der Nacht eben falls
aufgegriffen mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit waren sie schon sehr
lange auf einen Transporter gewesen dass
diese Person wirklich schon sehr
erschöpft sind auch hier folgen
erkennungsdienstliche Maßnahmen
Fingerabdrücke computerabgleich ob ein
Haftbefehl vorliegt dann heißt es warten
bis es weitergeht in eine
Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung die Schleuser
werden festgenommen sitzen in Gewahrsam
nebenan da die Regierung jetzt die
Strafen verschärft hat droht ihn schon
bei Minders schweren Fällen mindestens
eine Freiheitsstrafe von einem
Jahr mit den Schleusern habe ich absolut
kein mittelleid weil das ist ein ganz
schmutziges Geschäft ein kriminelles
Geschäft ein kriminelles
Reisebüro sie bekommen Auftrag fahren zu
ein Ort nemen Person interessiert nicht
woher sie kommen hier geht's einfach nur
um Geld verdienen und wenn es geht ganz
schnelles Geld verdienen bis September
gab es aus Tschechien übrigens 12 143
illegale Einreisen nach Deutschland im
ganzen Jahr 2022 waren es rund 16 000
für Natalie und Tarik geht es derweil
erst einmal zum letzten Standort denn in
ihrer Schicht überprüfen Sie auch noch
die Straßenbahn die aus der Schweiz
kommen auch diese werden derzeit noch
intensiver kontrolliert wir sind jetzt
weil rein Friedlingen wir kontrollieren
jetzt die Tram 8 die kommt dann hier
angefahren und die kommt eben aus der
Schweiz und hier ist dann eben
Deutschland eine Kontrolle bitte genau
wie bei den anderen Maßnahmen wird hier
deutlich sie sind aufwendig und binden
etliche Beamte zudem sind gerade feste
Kontrollen für Schleuser leicht
auszuspen und zu umgehen experten
kritisieren daher die Maßnahmen fordern
stattdessen funktionierende Abkommen
damit Migranten erst gar nicht nach
Europa kommen oder konsequent
abgeschoben werden können doch dass er
eine andere eine politische Diskussion
heißt es hier und so setzen Natalie
Tarik und ihre Kollegen ihre Einsätze an
deutschlandsgrenzen erst einmal wie
gehabt fort gegen illegale Migration und
das lukrative Geschäft der Schleuser
genau für uns geht jetzt weiter in die
nächste
Bahn